ces lieux c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir un
temps en 2009 c'est tout
[Musique]
je m'appelle josé y est j'ai 20 ans
j'habite à fontaine d'ouche à dijon et
je suis en recherche d'emploi dans
l'administratif
[Musique]
à ma copine c'est wallace et il faut
tout lui dire je vais me poser avec elle
via rigolé pendant pendant trois heures
on va regarder les mêmes films voilà on
va on va faire du shopping
voilà c'est comme ça qu'un danser
s'amuser sortir broyage et quand je suis
arrivé en france en demi je tends
sandell et puis après on est parti vivre
à quétigny pour un foyer aussi et on me
trouvait à la porte et m'a ici donc ça
fait 16 ans connaît là dans le quartier
on connaît en est un qui connaît tout le
monde
entre noirs aux travaux entre blanton
que je connais à peu près donc que c'est
c'est cool au lycée je voulais aller en
accompagnement soins et services à la
personne ça m'a pas du tout plu vous
voyez pas ça comme ça et du coup j'ai
changé de filière pour aller en bac pro
gestion administration
j'ai eu mon bep mon bafa l'horaire c'est
compliqué de trouver un emploi après un
bac je participe inscrits à la mission
locale et ma conseillère m'a demandé si
je voulais faire partie de la garantie g
elle m'a expliqué qu'en gros c'est une
sorte d' aide pour trouver un emploi
mais tant que tu n'as pas d'emploi te
faire des stages et en gros que les mois
tuée rémunéré pour ses dans la vie de
tous les jours
j'aurais aussi une aide pour faire mon
père ami
je
toi je faisais ligne de manille moi je
vais travailler mais dans quoi où
comment t'as pas d'idées ça va être
beaucoup plus compliqué de dire je vais
axé là-dessus là dessus c était à
refaire nos cv à trouver nos qualités et
nos défauts pour avancer dans notre
recherche d'emploi dans des
professionnels parce qu'ils m'ont
vraiment ce que les employeurs
recherchent
quand ils nous regardent nous ces villes
ont de défense du mais pourquoi je
mettrai ça sur mon cv mais des fois ça
aide beaucoup
c'est compliqué et que même l'âge de
trouver un stage pour se dépasser pour
trois stages c'est compliqué
ils vont pas trop se voir peut-être
c'est très dur pour nous quand on est
noir c'est déjà compliqué de vivre comme
ça normalement
par exemple un jour on m'a refusé une
candidature dans gauche parce que sont
la photo eh ben j'ai les cheveux comme
ça donc ils ont refusé je me suis donc
dit oui votre coiffure n'est pas
professionnel c'est mes cheveux
avoir 20 ans c'est l'âge où on vraiment
profite on sort on voyage voilà même les
bottes de nubuck fermé
et là on peut rien faire du tout apport
se voir chez des amis en petit comité
du coup c'est dur c'est vraiment c'est
compliqué dans 20 ans je me vois en
suisse dans ma maison avec mes enfants
et moi petite entreprise